it's not often you get a view like this
on a flight but passengers on their way
back from Iceland were treated to this
360 view of the northern lights after
their pilot made a 10-minute control
detour to the west of the Pharaoh
Islands the phenomena are A Feast for
the eyes let alone in Britain where the
extraordinary display has been spotted
for two consecutive nights taking
thousands by surprise
clear skies and a solar storm meant
wedding photographer Robin saw them
dancing above his home in Dorset I've
always wanted to see the Northern Lights
all my life and I first got on
opportunity just before Christmas we
went to Finland and that was just
absolutely incredible
um and I never thought I'd see them
again so soon afterwards but I think
seeing them in the UK is perhaps even
more special because it's because it's
here and we all dream of going to all
these places where you see them but
there's a good chance for everybody to
see them in the UK it's just just
amazing
there are spectacle usually seen in the
clear skies of Norway Finland and
Iceland astronomer Tom cares has seen
the sweeping curtains more than a
hundred times here's what he witnessed
last week in Norway but he says we can
see this magic closer to home events
like the one that we've seen for the
past couple of nights are quite
extraordinarily rare however Aurora
sightings in general are becoming more
common as we approach the peak of the
solar cycle so if you're willing to make
the trip if you're in the UK you could
always consider Scotland you don't have
to go overseas but if you want to
consider a trip for this season or
perhaps the next one as we go into the
autumn and winter next year well you're
going to have very good chances to see
beautiful displays these increasingly
unexpected appearances bringing a show
with joy and wonder to our own back
Gardens ashnaharinag Sky News